PETER LUBBERS: Welcome to
"Google Developers Live" here
on the Chrome channel.
And today we have a really
exciting episode of a new
series, "Ask the Author," where
new book authors explain
about their book and the new,
exciting technologies they're
talking about.
So with me I have talking about
"The Definitive Guide to
HTML5 WebSocket," I have the
three authors that wrote it,
starting with the first one,
Vanessa, Vanessa Wang.
Welcome.
VANESSA WANG: Thanks, Peter.
I'm Vanessa Wang.
I'm one of the authors
of the book.
I'm currently manager of
technical publications at
Kaazing, which is a start-up
in Mountain View, where I
write documentation for our
WebSocket platform.
PETER LUBBERS: Great.
And Peter Moskovits.
PETER MOSKOVITS:
Hi, I am Peter.
And I head up real-time
solutions at Kaazing.
And I work very closely
with the developer
community out there.
PETER LUBBERS: Great.
And Frank, Frank Salim.
FRANK SALIM: I'm Frank.
I am a software engineer
at Google and I
used to work at Kaazing.
PETER LUBBERS: Full disclosure,
I also used to
work at Kaazing, so it feels
like a little bit
of a reunion here.
So tell us a little about
the book in general.
What can we expect to find
in the book, Vanessa?
VANESSA WANG: We started off the
book with a little history
of why WebSocket.
And then we go into the
API and protocol.
So the standard is comprised of
the WebSocket protocol, the
communication protocol,
and the API that
interfaces with it.
And then we deep dive into three
hands-on examples of how
to use WebSocket with higher
level protocols, such as XMPP,
which is a chat application, and
STOMP for pub/sub and VNC,
which is a binary protocol.
We also go into some of the
security and deployment
considerations at the end.
PETER LUBBERS: Great.
Yeah.
I saw a great appendix as
well on how to debug it.
And we'll get back
to that as well.
So why did you think--
when you started writing the
book, Peter, what prompted you
to do that?
Why was it a good time
to [INAUDIBLE]?
PETER MOSKOVITS: It was a long
time until WebSocket became a
ratified standard.
In December, 2011,
it was accepted.
RFC is out there.
And we felt that there's a need
to share the experience
that we have gathered
at Kaazing.
We started it over 4, 4 and
1/2 years ago there.
And we wanted to share so
that people can get
started and use it.
PETER LUBBERS: Great.
All right.
So maybe just for everyone
that's watching and has
questions about WebSocket, by
the way, on the YouTube
channel we have a link to the
questions, the moderator.
So we have a moderator
where you can
vote and ask questions.
Definitely use that.
We're going to get back to those
questions at the end of
this program.
And for now we'll talk a little
bit more about this.
So what are some of the core
concepts, before we dive too
deep into it.
What is WebSocket?
Maybe for those of you
that don't know.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Maybe
I will take that.
And then others can chime in.
WebSocket allows you to have
a full duplex always-on
connection between your browser
and a WebSocket server.
And it allows you to build
applications that we've been
trying to build for
a long time.
When we first moved to the web,
initially it was around
static and then later on dynamic
documents, getting
these documents into
the browser.
And the browser was used
in a pretty dumb way.
And then as a browsers evolved
and JavaScript engines became
more powerful, clearly we could
start moving some of the
business logic that was running
on the application
servers and the middlewares
over to the browser.
And around the same time, it
was clear that we needed a
better way to connect these
applications that are running
in the browser.
And WebSocket addresses that.
And not only does it have
this very low latency
communication, it's also
designed to be web-friendly.
I mean, we can talk about this
a little bit later on.
But the whole idea that with
HTML5 basically applications
running natively in the browser
without the need of
extra plug-ins and extra
extensions, it
can become very powerful.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
For example, Flash has
a socket, right?
I think there was a question
about that on the moderator
we'll get back to later.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Exactly.
Flash has socket.
Java has socket.
And doing this whole socket
connection in a
standards-based way, where
everybody does it the same
way, and you can assume that it
works across the board and
how well it works-- again,
I guess we can talk
about that later on--
is what makes it really
nice and powerful.
PETER LUBBERS: Very good.
Yeah.
It's very exciting
to see a complete
book devoted to WebSocket.
One of the things I liked about
your book was the demo
VM that you shipped.
So most books, of course, have
a GitHub repository.
I believe you have that too.
But to get started with
WebSocket, of course it
requires a client, but
also a server.
And that's maybe different from
other parts of HTML5,
which is usually sort of
like a client-side API
and you can use that.
But for WebSocket, you do need
that other endpoint.
So tell us a little bit, or
maybe you can demo it.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Sure.
Maybe I can give you a quick
idea here on my machine.
So the first thing that you
mentioned was GitHub.
If you go to GitHub and you
search for WebSocket book, the
source code is easily
accessible, grouped by
chapters here.
In addition to this, you can
also download a VM along with
the source code from the
publisher's website.
So all you need to do is again,
search for WebSocket on
the Apress site.
And here you see the book.
And on the bottom of this page,
there is a Source Code
and Downloads.
And this is where you
can download the VM.
The VM is very
straightforward, relatively small.
Its starts up in no time.
It's a virtual box VM and
has Ubuntu on it.
PETER LUBBERS: And you just
need a VirtualBox player.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Yes.
That's all you need.
You get VirtualBox and you
can open up the VM.
PETER LUBBERS: Perfect.
Cool.
So can you give a quick
demo of how you would
start it and use it?
PETER MOSKOVITS: Sure.
So actually I have already
started up the VM.
When you take a look at it here,
you see the chapters out
there on the desktop.
There is a readme file that
comes with every chapter.
So when you open it up, you see
the readme file that gives
you the steps that are related
to the actual chapter.
All the source code
is obviously
included here as well.
And in addition, we also have
a video that is in every
folder here.
So this is a set of screencasts
that walk you
through the steps of doing
these hands-on kind of
exercises in this environment,
step by step.
So it's really easy and really
straightforward.
Maybe I can quickly start one.
And just basically this
is the experience.
VANESSA WANG: One of the
purposes of the VM was really
just to give different access
points to the code.
So you can walk through the code
in GitHub, but also if
you don't really learn that way,
you can just start it up
on the VM and then walk
backwards following the
examples in the book, and then
figure out how it was built
just by looking at the VM.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
I like that, because that's
often the problem.
Sometimes you don't have time
to see the whole thing.
You can see the finished
solution and
quickly get to the--
FRANK SALIM: Without having
to bootstrap a lot of
environments.
Each of these chapters might
have a different server that
comes with it that's
pre-configured in the VM.
There's a chat server and
a messaging server.
And they're all in there.
PETER LUBBERS: It's like
pre-seated servers.
FRANK SALIM: Right.
PETER LUBBERS: Awesome.
Great.
So we talked a little bit
about what WebSocket is.
But what are some of the
practical applications today
that you can accomplish
by using the standard?
PETER MOSKOVITS: So maybe
I can show a couple.
And then we can take the
discussion from there.
The first one is going to be a
demo that we like to call the
portfolio demo.
One of the typical use cases for
WebSocket is that you have
a large amount of data available
on the server.
And you want to get this data
to a number of clients, to
typically a large number of
clients, very quickly and then
basically at real-time.
And this is one of the demos
that showcases this.
So what you see here
is imaginary data.
It's not real market
data, obviously--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
that we are showing here.
And depending on your network
connection, I saw a bit of a
stop there, you see
the data come in.
So one of the things that you
can do is you can open a new
browser window.
And this demo is available on
the public internet, so you
can go to the URL that
you see here.
And you can run this
demo yourself.
You can execute--
basically the data is coming
from the server to the client.
This is something that's not
very easy to do when you're
using HTTP.
But it also shows the
bi-directional nature of
WebSocket, where not only do you
see the data coming in but
you can also initiate trading.
PETER LUBBERS: So to
buy a stock, you
would send a message.
And they receive messages.
Right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I think that demo really
highlights a lot of the cool
parts about WebSocket as opposed
to what are typically
called Comet implementations
that are basically HTTP
requests that are either polling
or long polling.
So what's the typical reduction
of overhead in
something like this that
you would find?
PETER MOSKOVITS: So when you
speak HTTP, along with the
request and the response there
is a number of headers that
are sent over.
And these headers can range from
800 to 1,500, sometimes
even 2,000 bytes.
And when it comes to sending and
receiving small amounts of
data at a high frequency,
then it all adds
up very, very quickly.
With WebSocket, the header and
the overhead is in the number
of bytes, four, six,
eight, bytes.
So when you're sending over a
character or a small number or
something really small, then
it can be 100- or even
1,00-fold, the speed improvement
that you can
achieve, which is impressive,
especially when you have
hundreds of thousands or
millions of users out there.
PETER LUBBERS: Cool.
So in the book, you
said here JMS.
So in the book I noticed you
talk a lot about of course
there's the core WebSocket,
that is
the API and the protocol.
But then you also talked
about XMPP.
You mentioned STOMP or remote
frame buffers, the VNC
protocol, I guess,
if you will.
Tell us a little bit about
what the architecture for
something like that
would look like.
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
So WebSocket really lends
itself to a layered
architecture where if
you treat it like a
transport-level protocol, like
an analog-to-TCP, and speak
application-level protocols
on top of that, that's an
approach that we think works
really nicely and we describe
at length in the book.
PETER LUBBERS: Is it also
part of the standard?
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
So the standard contains
support for
higher-level protocols.
They're called sub-protocols,
which maybe isn't the most
straightforward term.
But with the standard you can
create a connection that
negotiates a protocol with
a name, a named protocol.
And the contents of the
WebSocket conversation will
adhere to that other protocol.
PETER LUBBERS: But have any
browsers shipped with any
sub-protocol support
today, or not yet?
FRANK SALIM: Support for
the sub-protocol
feature is baked in.
And it's more up to the
application to bring along
sub-protocol support as part
of a JavaScript library.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
I see.
PETER MOSKOVITS: So here on my
screen I quickly brought up a
diagram that kind of talks to
this point, where you have
your clients on the
left-hand side.
You have the WebSocket
connection going all the way
to your WebSocket server.
And then you have a TCP
connection all the
way to the back end.
And typically, the TCP
connection that you have on
the back end can be really any
rich business protocol.
But when you have a traditional
web application,
you basically break that
bidirectional connection as
you go out to your
web clients.
And this is what WebSocket
is addressing.
And not only do you have the
full duplex connectivity
between your clients and your
WebSocket server that can then
be basically connected all the
way to the back end, but very
much like on TCP, you can build
these higher level,
richer protocols.
So interestingly from a server's
perspective, you
don't necessarily or don't even
know whether the client
that is connecting is connecting
over TCP or over
WebSocket, as long as it speaks
that specific protocol.
XMPP is a good example.
And we have an example
for that in the book.
PETER LUBBERS: Great.
Well, before we dive into any
further examples, what's the
level of support
like right now?
Like what browsers and
especially the mobile
browsers, what's the
support landscape?
And Where can I find out?
PETER MOSKOVITS: So maybe here
I can show caniuse.com.
So if you filter this for
WebSocket, you see where we
stand today.
It shows that the currently-used
browsers, 58%,
59% of them do support WebSocket
natively, which is
good on one hand.
It's pretty bad if you consider
that you may be
losing 30%, 33% percent of
your users who are going
against the WebSocket-enabled
application.
So that is a challenge.
This is something that we see
out there that people are
struggling with.
So it's very important that you
make sure that whatever
server you're using, you have
the right level of emulation
or fallback to support all those
browsers that do not
have native support.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah, like
polyfill libraries and so on.
FRANK SALIM: It's worth
mentioning that the latest
version of all the
major desktop
browsers support WebSocket.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
That's a big deal, right?
So IE10 joined.
FRANK SALIM: The future
looks good.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah, that's
actually pretty good, the
percentage there, because you're
always going to have
sort of the old ID that's
not going to support it.
I mean, it's more like what's
happening in the future
browsers that's important.
PETER MOSKOVITS: I was thinking
I have another demo
that maybe we can show.
PETER LUBBERS: Perfect.
Yeah.
PETER MOSKOVITS: So we saw the
use case where we have a lot
of data coming in from the
server and we want to share
this with a number of clients.
Another interesting use case
that was really hard to
achieve before the world of
WebSocket is this peer-to-peer
or pseudo-peer-to-peer
kind of connection.
So one of the first kind of
quick demos that I built when
I started looking into WebSocket
is a demo called the
Bouncy Ball Demo.
And I'm going to bring up a
simulator here and open the
same page here in
the simulator.
And just to play safe, I'll
reload this page.
And what we see here is that
the two are side by side.
And maybe I can resize this
Chrome window here a little
bit so they can be truly
side by side.
And what we can do is with a
simple tap gesture on the
phone, we can connect
these two screens.
You see there are basically two
HTML pages with canvases
rendered in there.
And when I tap and--
demo is not behaving.
Let's try again.
Let's try that again.
They would basically
share the screen.
Here we go.
And when we actually--
ah.
I may need to.
Here we go.
So what happens is the two
screens are connected, so
basically they negotiate
who is on the left and
who is on the right.
And when the ball comes to a
shared wall, then a message is
sent from one browser to the
other through the WebSocket
server indicating that the
ball is coming at this
position, this is the speed,
this is the direction where
it's heading, you take over
the rendering now.
And then the other browser
can render.
It's important to mention
that this is not a true
peer-to-peer connection.
It goes through the server.
But you can achieve the--
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
There have actually been a few
moderator questions we'll get
to later talking about the
connection with WebRTC.
So let's come back to that.
So that's just basically a
canvas implementation on both
clients, right?
PETER MOSKOVITS: Right.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Actually, I
happen to have another one if
this is a good time.
This one is a video that shows
a WebGL car on a screen.
This is a pretty cool
car by itself.
And in the bottom right
corner, what
you see is my phone.
And as I am tilting the phone,
I am time driving the car.
And the way it happens is I have
a browser run on my phone
as well detect the
tilt status.
And as quickly as I can, I'm
sending messages to the
connected WebSocket server.
And since they share a server,
it can be bounced back using
this reflector model.
And it can be done very quickly
and very easily if you
are using concepts like pub/sub
on top of WebSocket.
PETER LUBBERS: High speed
messaging, basically.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Yeah.
Exactly.
PETER LUBBERS: That's
excellent.
Yeah.
I like that demo a lot.
That's really cool.
So what do you see--
what other sort of applications
are being built
today with WebSocket?
What's happening
in that world?
VANESSA WANG: So in addition to
some of the examples Peter
outlined, which is large amounts
of small bits of data
being sent out to multiple
clients at the same time,
we're also seeing a lot of
gaming being developed.
Browser-based games are using
WebSocket, especially like
MMO-type games.
I think Mozilla did a
BrowserQuest game a little
while ago, so did Rob Hawkes
with twitterrocks.com.
Sorry.
It was called Rawkets,
I think.
PETER LUBBERS: Oh
yeah, Rawkets.
VANESSA WANG: Yeah.
But we also see some other
ways that people might be
using this for like
crowdsourcing-type apps, like
Waze, something like a GPS for
traffic conditions, where a
lot of people need to
send lots of data
over the web in real-time.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Yeah.
Waze is really cool.
One of their recent
features is that--
PETER LUBBERS: The GPS app.
PETER MOSKOVITS: The
GPS app, yeah.
You enter an address.
You navigate somewhere.
And then you can share your
trip with somebody else.
So in their browser, they can
basically follow how you're
getting to a given point.
So you go and pick up somebody,
and they can see
where you are stuck in traffic
and how it goes.
Now, I don't believe
they use WebSocket.
And I actually I think their
refresh rate is somewhere in
the 30 second or maybe
1 minute rate.
But if they would be using
WebSocket, then they would be
able to see true
real-time data.
PETER LUBBERS: That's cool.
That's great.
Where do you see--
IE only added the support, what,
like last year, right,
when IE10 came out.
So fast forward two to three
years, even five years.
Where do you see like with
ubiquitous, fast connections
and everything on mobile, what
sort of applications do you
envision for WebSocket?
PETER MOSKOVITS: We already
see a lot of interest in
machine-to-machine
communication, [INAUDIBLE]
of things.
There's an interesting company
that I talked to not too long
ago where they have the ability
to produce these
little devices in a very cheap
and very efficient manner
where they can basically put
out and monitor things like
parking spots that are available
in cities, or attach
them to fire extinguishers.
So when basically the amount of
data that you want to send
over is typically very small,
most of the time the data that
you want to send over doesn't
have the real-time
requirement, but potentially
there is a very large number
of these devices that are out
there, so basically the
communication can be
done really well.
The monitoring aspect, when you
are building dashboards
that can be an interesting
use case.
PETER LUBBERS: That's great.
Any other--
VANESSA WANG: Similarly, we're
seeing some use cases in
transportation, also like
tracking cars, where cars are
going and being able to
report back, trains,
planes, you name it.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Another tricky
one is second-screen
kinds of applications, where
you're watching a show or you
are watching a sports event, and
then you can interact with
kind of the system and
you can interact with
other viewers as well.
We helped a film festival
last year.
And they were doing a quiz and
trivia game before the movies.
And they had real-time voting
after the movies.
It's a nice alternative to
basically marking up or
writing your vote for an
audience award movie when you
can use your phone.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
One of the chapters in your book
that I really liked was
the RFB protocol, the
remote desktop.
I think that's another very
powerful way to use it.
So in your VM, you actually
have a VNC server set up?
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
PETER LUBBERS: That's cool.
FRANK SALIM: You get the kind of
hall of mirrors effect with
the default configuration,
because the VNC server is the
same VM where you have
the browser.
You get the infinite
recursive window.
PETER LUBBERS: But
still, very cool.
FRANK SALIM: That's there.
You can easily reconfigure
to point to a
different VNC server.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
Is that using sort of the
binary message types of
WebSocket or just--
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
That's sending binary
data over WebSocket.
And there's a JavaScript library
that implements the
Remote Frame Buffer protocol.
PETER LUBBERS: There's so many
great things out there.
So one of the things I want to
talk about a little bit is the
debugging of these
connections.
So we have for example, in
Chrome Dev Tools, good ways to
look under the hood and let
us see what's happening.
What is your debugging workflow
for a WebSocket
application?
PETER MOSKOVITS: So let
me get started with
that here on my machine.
Let's bring up Chrome
Dev Tools.
And connect to websocket.org.
websocket.org is an
awesome website.
It has a lot of nice resources,
examples, good articles.
So it's a good place
to get started.
The echo test is a very nice
service where basically you
can create a WebSocket
connection, send some data to
the server.
And all the server does is
it echoes it back to you.
So it's pretty much the first
test that people use if they
want to basically test
what they have.
So I'm going to create
a connection.
And when you switch over to
the Network tab and we can
filter by WebSocket, what we
see here is the actual
WebSocket connection.
And then we talked about
WebSocket beating
web-friendly, which means that
actually it starts its life as
an HTTP connection.
So interestingly, WebSocket
connection is symmetric.
So the server can send
data asynchronously.
And the client can send
So it's bi-directional.
But the way it gets created,
that is asymmetric in the
sense that it's always the
client that has to initiate
the connection.
So basically the browser says
or the client, the WebSocket
client, says that, hey, I want
to create a connection and
then, do you speak WebSocket?
And the server responds, yes,
I do speak WebSocket.
And that's when the HTTP
connection breaks down and the
new connection, the WebSocket
connection, takes over.
FRANK SALIM: And we can see
the handshake here, the
request and response, with
all of the headers.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Right.
FRANK SALIM: Might want to make
it a little bit bigger.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Here we go.
So here is the upgrade
header that is sent.
And here in the response is
the upgrade header too.
PETER LUBBERS: Cool.
PETER MOSKOVITS: OK.
And so once we have the
connection established--
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
Then you have the messaging
that goes back and forth.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Exactly.
So what you can do here
on websocket.org is
you can send a message.
And we see the message
was sent.
And the response was sent back,
which is the same message.
So let's click on the
connection again.
And here we can inspect
the frames.
Here the background color
indicates whether it was an
upstream or a downstream.
You can see the length
of the message.
And you can see the
time as well.
So if you are sending a new
message, you would need to
click on the connection
again to refresh the
actual frames in here.
So another thing that we
could do here is--
let me bring up the console.
And from the console itself,
we do have a WebSocket
connection variable here.
So here you can see the actual
connected WebSockets.
You see the endpoint here.
And we can do websocket.send.
And here we can say something
like, "Hi there." And when you
do this, what happens is the
message is sent from the
console, not from
the application.
So actually, I did say
"hi there" again.
I should have said
something else.
But basically--
thank you.
FRANK SALIM: Excuse me.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Here we go.
So from the application
we don't log
the outgoing message.
We only get back the incoming
message, simply because the
message was not sent
from the app.
It was sent from the console.
So it kind of gives you an idea
of how you can use Chrome
to kind of visualize WebSocket,
which by the way is
quite a challenge, because
it's all kind
of under the covers.
And it's very handy.
And it's there.
You don't have to install
or get anything.
It's just there at your
fingertips right away.
PETER LUBBERS: What are some of
the other tools you might
be using for the analysis?
FRANK SALIM: Do we
want to look at
Netinternals maybe first?
PETER MOSKOVITS: Sure.
PETER LUBBERS: So where
are you going?
Chrome.
Right.
Yeah.
FRANK SALIM: Even more
under the hood.
Tools for inspecting
the network stack.
So even if a WebSocket doesn't
connect and maybe you have a
DNS stall out or some other
connection issue before you
get that far, you can look
in Netinternals.
But I think where you're going
is, what if that's not enough?
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
FRANK SALIM: In the case where
you have a WebSocket client,
your browser and a WebSocket
server that speaks the
protocol, and everything is
working fine, this is almost
always enough information.
You can see your handshake.
You can see the payload
of WebSocket messages
flying back and forth.
If you're writing a new
WebSocket server and you need
to make sure that the syntax of
the WebSocket messages is
correct, you might go for
network-level tracing, where
Wireshark is an incredibly
powerful tool.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
Show us that.
FRANK SALIM: Let's take
a look at that.
PETER LUBBERS: The power.
FRANK SALIM: I'll just refresh
websocket.org again and bring
up Wireshark.
PETER LUBBERS: So Wireshark,
you can just
download that for free?
FRANK SALIM: Yes.
Open source application.
We'll start a capture on the
wireless device here, and
filter for port 80, where web
traffic will be found.
All right.
And we'll start this WebSocket
connection
and send a few messages.
And over here, we should see
the complete bytes of both
sides of the network session,
including framing and masking,
which are below the level
of where the JavaScript
application would have
visibility or care about.
PETER LUBBERS: Yes.
So you could never get from
within the [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SALIM: Right.
And it looks like with later
versions of Wireshark, it will
actually dissect the WebSocket
message and show you the
fields in the WebSocket
message header.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
Well, that's great.
So basically for
anything that--
like your regular JavaScript
applications that are let's
say working, you can get it
from Chrome Dev Tools.
If you're building things more
advanced, like a server, then
you might go to the
Wireshark layer.
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
If you're doing a new
implementation of the
protocol, Wireshark
can be very handy.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
VANESSA WANG: Yeah.
We walk through using Chrome Dev
Tools, Netinternals, and
Wireshark in the book as well.
PETER LUBBERS: In the final
appendix, right, or one of the
appendices.
FRANK SALIM: We do write a
WebSocket server in Chapter 3,
so there is an occasion where
you might want to do this kind
of debugging.
VANESSA WANG: Exactly.
PETER LUBBERS: That's great.
All right.
So before we jump into the
questions on the moderator,
Vanessa, you're a doc manager.
You've written tons
of documentation.
How did you find this writing an
actual book different from
writing docs?
VANESSA WANG: Well, first it
was we're bringing about a
technology, a standard,
rather than a product.
And that was definitely a shift
in just the process.
And then thinking about the best
way to explain something
that people will be approaching
in a number of
different ways, and not
having any sort of
predictability there.
So it was a really
good process.
It was a really intense
process.
PETER LUBBERS: Having written
a book on the side, I'm sure
you're happy that it's done.
Great.
Well, let's take a look
at a couple of
questions on the moderator.
So if you have any questions,
on the YouTube live stream
there are links to ask and
vote for more questions.
So let's go to the presentation
view here.
All right.
So what considerations in terms
of scalability should
you take when deploying a
WebSocket-based service.
In particular, what limits do
you hit easier due to having
to keep many connections open?
So that's I guess a commonly
asked question, right?
Because with HTTP requests,
it's sort of the request,
response, and it's done.
Here you now have a whole new
paradigm of potentially
thousands or millions of
concurrent connections.
So how do you deal with the
scalability of that?
This is from Vlad from London.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Sure.
Maybe I'll start and then
others can chime in.
So one of the challenges that
we've been facing in the
pre-WebSocket world is that
as we moved to the web, we
started using the web in a way
that we expected kind of the
client-server world to work.
So just because we moved to the
web and just because the
web was not designed for the
richness and the interactivity
that we had in the client-server
world, that
doesn't mean that customers and
people basically gave up
on that need or on
that demand.
So we came up with a number of
these very creative ways of
introducing interactivity.
And we were using HTTP, a very
scalable and stateless
protocol for something that
it was not designed for.
And by using something that was
specifically designed for
this use case, I think we can
write our applications in a
way more efficient manner.
Very often I get the question
whether HTTP gets replaced by
WebSocket, or what this whole
coexistence story is.
And basically HTTP is there for
all the document-oriented
resources, things like images
and HTML5 files and CSS and
JavaScript.
And WebSocket can be used for
where it's really good, where
you need to have this permanent
connection for the
bidirectional communication.
On the scalability side, yes, it
can be a challenge, simply
because when you get started
with WebSocket, basically you
can build amazing things.
And as you start rolling it out
to the web, you can face
thousands, tens of thousands,
hundreds of
thousands of users.
And suddenly things
can break down.
How you do clustering, how you
do failover, how you do
disaster recovery, all these
kinds of questions come up.
We did a benchmark
not too long ago.
And in that benchmark, we had a
million concurrent connected
users served by one server.
VANESSA WANG: A server
rack, right?
PETER MOSKOVITS: It was a rack.
Exactly.
We had 10 messages sent
per second to
these 1 million users.
The message size
was 512 bytes.
The protocol overhead was
another 100 or 200 bytes.
And we did not have a single
dropped connection.
And the overhead that we added
on top of the actual physical
network overhead, that the
WebSocket stack added on top
of that the average was I think
3 and 1/2 milliseconds.
So it can scale.
But if you want to scale to a
very large number of users,
then you have to have those
capabilities in the server
that you are using.
PETER LUBBERS: Sure.
Makes sense.
VANESSA WANG: Actually,
that brings up
an interesting point.
One of the things that we talk
about in the book is enabling
your server to speak
WebSocket.
So that would be your browser
or your client talking to
WebSocket, to a WebSocket
server, versus using a server
in between that translates
WebSocket traffic into TCP
through the back end.
And those are two different
options that we go
through in the book.
PETER LUBBERS: Cool.
PETER MOSKOVITS: So speaking of
the book, and I don't know
whether that would fit into
any of the questions.
Maybe it would.
PETER LUBBERS: Buy it.
Buy the book.
PETER MOSKOVITS: There are a
couple of very, very neat
examples that I think we
built for the book.
So maybe we can show
some of them.
We have some here in the VM.
And maybe we can walk through
what whole experience is just
to basically show how easy
it is to get started.
So the first one is Chapter 3.
FRANK SALIM: Right.
So in Chapter 3, we go through
building a WebSocket server
from scratch, using nojs
on the server side.
And that's really nice that we
get to keep the same language
for these examples on the client
and on the server.
So we write the server.
And we have a couple of fun
little things you can do with
it, the basic just echoing
messages back and forth, and
also a WebSocket REPL.
So we have a read-eval-print
loop that you run on the
server side that executes
JavaScript remotely on all the
connected clients.
So I'll just start
that up here.
I'll go to the Chapter 3
directory and run start REPL
server dot sh, which is just
executing node and this
WebSocket REPL JavaScript
application.
I'll open a couple of browser
windows, I hope, and just open
the client in each window.
And we'll see here on the
server a couple of
connections came in.
And so whatever we type here in
the console is going to be
executed by each of
the browsers.
And the results going to be
returned over WebSocket.
And it's going to print out
here again on the console.
So just 1 plus 1, each browser
ran the JavaScript
expression 1 plus 1.
That was delivered to it
over the WebSocket.
It comes back it's 2.
So each session printed out 2.
So we can do some pretty
fun things with that.
For instance, we can manipulate
the actual pages
run in each of these browsers.
PETER LUBBERS: Oh wow.
That's great.
PETER MOSKOVITS: So you're
basically writing JavaScript
commands that are sent over,
executed on each of these
browsers, and you are
controlling the browser remotely.
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
It's a remote control
application, driven by a
WebSocket server.
PETER MOSKOVITS: It's pretty
impressive, especially when
you have a browser on the other
side of the planet and
you are remotely
controlling it.
It can have a pretty
interesting effect.
PETER LUBBERS: It brings
up the question
of security, Frank.
FRANK SALIM: Security's
very important.
PETER LUBBERS: Let's take
another quick question from
the moderator.
So from Frank G. in New York.
We have, what is the
relationship between WebRTC
and WebSocket.
And we talked about this
briefly before.
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
This comes up a lot, because the
one-sentence description
of WebRTC is this real-time
communication feature for browsers.
And the one-sentence description
of WebSocket is a
real-time communication
feature for browsers.
So the headline is
very similar.
But WebSocket has a
client-server model.
It's a very data-centric
use case.
And WebRTC is peer-to-peer with
a really heavy focus on
real-time media.
That's what it's really
designed for.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
Video, audio.
FRANK SALIM: And it supports
peer-to-peer data with
optional reliability.
And so there are some
overlapping use cases.
But they're really on the
margins of what they're
designed for.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
Cool.
Actually, speaking of security,
what type of
security should big companies
consider when offering a
persistent connection to their
back end services?
Also from Frank in New York.
FRANK SALIM: Well, should big
companies offer connections
directly to their back
end services?
PETER LUBBERS: That's
a good question.
FRANK SALIM: Well, first of
all, should they offer
connections directly to
the back end services?
PETER LUBBERS: Let's
take a step back.
So what are some of the
WebSocket security
considerations like you talked
about in the book?
What does it boil down to?
FRANK SALIM: So it has
transport-level security, much
like HTTPS with WebSocket
Secure, the
WSS scheme over TLS.
And it starts with an HTTP
connection, so you have
headers there that you can
use for authentication.
You can use cookies.
And then if you use it as a
transport-layer protocol,
that's basically what you get.
You can have application-level
security on top, basically
bring your own.
Otherwise, it's a pipe which
can be encrypted.
PETER LUBBERS: Anything
to add?
PETER MOSKOVITS: And then
there are a number of
additional security-related
capabilities that
some servers offer.
So when it comes to kind of
real-life deployments, then
you may be interested in SSO
integration, Kerberos
integration.
You may be interested in
protecting your environment.
There are some ways of
establishing a WebSocket
connection without opening
up any inbound
ports on your firewall.
So there's a large number of
things that you can deploy and
you can consider using when you
want to basically offer
these services to the web.
PETER LUBBERS: So once you get
into this enterprise scenario,
does WebSocket offer anything
specifically to go through
load balancers, firewalls,
by itself?
Or how should you
consider that?
That's pretty common in an
enterprise scenario, right?
PETER MOSKOVITS: Right.
So this is a major challenge,
because the plain WebSocket
connection very often gets cut
off by these proxies and
routers and firewalls.
So one typical thing that
improves the penetration is
when you use WebSocket Secure,
when you tunnel your WebSocket
connection over TLS then
it gets a lot better.
But even that doesn't get
you beyond 90% or 95%.
So at that point the question
is whether you can afford to
lose 5% or 10% of your potential
users or customers
or whether you want to have
complete coverage.
And again, this is
something where
implementations can differ.
So there are various
solutions.
You can fall back
to emulation.
And if you do that, then there
are ways you can penetrate
these intermediaries.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
Cool.
We'll take another question.
So that's basically the question
I just answered.
I didn't see that before.
So network entities, firewalls,
and proxies are not
very friendly to WebSocket.
What's the best way to use
WebSocket for connections that
traverse those entities?
So I guess the answer use WSS,
the WebSocket Secure.
PETER MOSKOVITS: That's a good
starting point, yes.
FRANK SALIM: That's a great
starting point.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Yes.
FRANK SALIM: Much better
[INAUDIBLE] with an encrypted
connection.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Basically,
very much like SPDY, you
probably would not want to have
a WebSocket connection,
just plain WebSocket connection,
unless you are in
a development or testing
environment.
In a production environment,
you do want to have TLS.
FRANK SALIM: Some otherwise
controlled network.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Exactly.
PETER LUBBERS: Cool.
So there's a question from
Shafir in Israel.
What about better tooling
to debug problems in the
WebSocket protocol, such as
bad Unicode encoding.
If the server generates a
WebSocket message the browser
doesn't like, it's almost
impossible to find where the
problem is.
Have you run into that?
FRANK SALIM: I have
not run into that.
I can imagine the problem.
So WebSocket text messages are
required to be UTF-8 encoded.
So if there's some
other encoding--
and ASCII will fly by, because
ASCII is a valid subset.
So most the time during
development you might be not
encoding and get away with
it on your server.
But if you have a UTF-16
encoded string in your
WebSocket payload, the browser
will reject that message.
PETER LUBBERS: But wouldn't
that be like a server
configuration issue in
general, or is that
something--
because your client is going
to speak-- your browser is
going to do the right
thing, right?
FRANK SALIM: Yes.
That's a server bug.
But it seems like it could be
a reasonably easy mistake to
make on the server.
PETER LUBBERS: I see.
Right.
Is there currently
something in, for
example, Chrome Dev Tools?
What would happen if you got
a message like that?
FRANK SALIM: It might just close
the connection silently
or it might surface
some error.
So I guess the question is,
can the browsers complain
about that more coherently?
PETER LUBBERS: Would Wireshark
be an answer here?
What do you think?
Maybe?
FRANK SALIM: I'm not sure.
Maybe.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
Cool.
All right.
Another question from Shafir
again in Israel.
When will we have built-in
compression for WebSocket?
So I think that was a proposal,
right, for something
to be added on top of the--
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
There's a draft for compression
on WebSockets.
I don't know the status
or direction of that.
But it's under discussion.
PETER LUBBERS: Is there any
implementation that you're
aware of that has done
anything with that?
FRANK SALIM: I wouldn't know.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
OK.
All right.
Lena in LA asked, is there a
good way to gracefully degrade
the use of WebSocket on browsers
that are capable of
versus those that are not?
So this is where it comes into
like polyfills for WebSocket.
So, Vanessa, do you have a--
VANESSA WANG: Well, we do talk
about that a little bit in our
deployment chapter.
We talk an emulation.
The company we work, Kaazing,
actually does provide some
libraries out of the box
to help with that.
And it's designed for any
platform that you're using,
like JavaScript, .NET, Flash.
There's also other ways to
do it that Peter can
probably speak to.
PETER LUBBERS: Do you have any
libraries out there, like I
think nojs comes
with Socket.IO.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Right.
Right.
So there's a wide variety
of WebSocket servers and
libraries out there.
Actually in the book, we do have
an appendix where we list
those that were available
when we had to submit
the book for print.
And many of them do
have better or
worse fallback or emulation.
Again, it boils down to how
important it is for you,
whether you're OK with a certain
percentage of your
users or not and where that
threshold is for you.
PETER LUBBERS: So another
question from
Shafir, maybe for Frank.
What is the default binary type
for a WebSocket blob when
that blob has no MIME type?
Does it make it useless?
Doesn't that make it useless?
FRANK SALIM: That's an
interesting question.
So WebSocket messages don't
have MIME types.
But your higher-level protocol
can contain that information.
So you could have some
description of the content
type in a previous message or
in some framing around that
blob or some headers that you
send along before reading the
blob in that can tell the
application what to do with
that blob, whether to
put into a video
or an image or texture.
PETER LUBBERS: Is that how you
would typically code that up?
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
I think it would be atypical to
just blast blobs from the
server and expect the client to
know what to do with them.
Although I guess that's
possible, because the server
and the client might both
be under the same--
control the same application.
The client could know what to
expect the encoding of the
blob to be.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
So let's take a step
back here.
The default binary
type is blob.
So what other types
can you use?
And how hard is it
to set that?
FRANK SALIM: Setting
is pretty easy.
There's a property on the
WebSocket object you set to
the name of the type you want.
The other option is you can
have a typed array.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
OK.
All right.
So a question from Stephen
Kagel in San Francisco.
Are content delivery networks
able to cache
WebSockets at all?
For instance, if I send a
request to retrieve some data
through the socket, will a CDN
be able to cache that response
if appropriate?
So I think that's a really
good question.
Answers?
PETER MOSKOVITS: I don't
have an answer.
I think we'll have to get
back to him on that.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
But I mean typically
this would be like
real-time data, right?
But I guess it sounds like a
pretty interesting use case
for public messages something
could be cached.
OK.
So we'll get back
to you on that.
WebSocket plus UDP-based
functionality, asked Oswald in
San Francisco.
What are your thoughts?
FRANK SALIM: Well, there's data
channels in WebRTC, which
is a WebSocket-like API with
a UDP-based protocol.
PETER LUBBERS: That's
part of WebRTC.
Yeah.
Exactly.
OK.
PETER MOSKOVITS: But WebSocket
doesn't support UDP.
FRANK SALIM: No.
WebSocket is on top of TCP.
Once it's no longer on TCP, it
wouldn't be a WebSocket.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
So that's pretty fundamental.
Yeah.
I guess the next step would
then be to look to explore
WebRTC and the data
channels, right?
So there's another question.
How do WebSockets work
with proxies?
Brandon Zachary.
So we've just discussed
that a little bit.
I guess the main thing is that
proxy servers typically tend
to strip some of the
headers off.
And there's a pretty extensive
diagram in the book that shows
the sort of possible scenarios
through that.
So definitely check
that out, Brandon.
Steven, again, does holding a
WebSocket connection open
involve holding a phone
radio connection open?
If so, does this have much of
an effect on battery life?
That's also a pretty
good question.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Yes.
So actually we haven't
specifically talked about
mobile devices.
But clearly slowly we are
getting to a point where the
web is accessed through more
mobile devices than desktop
devices and how it affects
this whole WebSocket and
always-on world.
So there are a number of
challenges with mobile.
I mean, the classic ones in
the HTML5 world would be
screen real estate.
But when it comes to
communication, one is the
level of connectivity that you
have, whether you can stay
connected all the time.
And very often when you are
driving through a tunnel or
you are flying, you do
get disconnected.
So that is one challenge, what
can you do about that?
And briefly the answer to that
challenge is that the
WebSocket layer does not
provide any reconnect
capabilities.
So it's a higher level that
would have to provide that
functionality, either a higher
level protocol, or you have to
do that on the application
level.
And to answer the question
specifically on battery life,
if you have a connection
open, that does affect
your battery life.
The amount of data that you are
transferring does affect
your battery life.
So in an ideal world you should
be aware on the server
side what kind of device you
are talking to, what
capabilities it has, and talk
to that device accordingly.
Let's say you have some
streaming kind of application.
You don't necessarily want to
send 100 or 200 messages per
second to a mobile device or
you can have a kind of a
slowdown, slowing down of the
messages as time goes by.
So there are a number of
strategies that you can use.
But it's definitely something
that you need to have in mind
and design your apps for.
PETER LUBBERS: Perfect.
So here's an interesting
question.
Fabito asks, what are the
main advantages of
WebSockets over Bayeux?
Remember Bayeux, Frank?
FRANK SALIM: I very vaguely
remember Bayeux from the
distant past.
PETER LUBBERS: I think as I
recall Bayeux was sort of
pub/sub-based?
FRANK SALIM: Pub/sub,
Comet stack?
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
It's been a while.
FRANK SALIM: Well, WebSocket is
in browsers, standardized.
I'm sure it has a number of
technical advantages, but
without remembering the details
of Bayeux, that's
going to be hard to
come up with.
PETER LUBBERS: Well, I think
you hit on it pretty well,
like WebSocket is the standard
and is implemented everywhere.
And it's not hard, as you've
shown in the book, to really
build some great applications
very quickly using some of
these other pub/sub protocols
on top of that stack.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Yeah. pub/sub
makes a giant difference.
And one point I wanted to make
earlier, actually, is that the
WebSocket API is very easy
to use and it's very
straightforward.
At the same time, it's very
low level as well.
And using something like pub/sub
or something that is
the right tool for the job
is highly recommended.
You can get your very
first, very easy
chat app up and running.
But when it comes to doing
something for real, you do
want to use some more
targeted tools.
And pub/sub is a great way.
Actually, most of the demos
that we showed in the
beginning use some pub/sub.
And in the book, we are
talking about STOMP
specifically.
And we use ActiveMQ as
a message broker.
PETER LUBBERS: What does
STOMP stand for?
PETER MOSKOVITS: Simple or
Streaming Text-Oriented
Message Protocol, which is a
very simple protocol, despite
the fact that it has the word
simple in its name.
So it is a simple protocol.
And you can learn.
And the demo that we give,
actually it's a game that's in
the VM that is a
rock-paper-scissors game.
So the idea is similar to what
we described earlier on.
So there are two players in
two separate browsers.
And they connect to each other
through a WebSocket server.
And they're publishing and
subscribing to these messages.
And that's how they
communicate.
PETER LUBBERS: So another
question from
Frank in New York.
Is WebSocket a replacement
for REST?
Any thoughts on that?
FRANK SALIM: So I
would say no.
And why?
Because they're pretty much
apples and oranges.
REST is an architectural
style and WebSocket
is a network protocol.
And you can build applications
in a RESTful style on top of
WebSockets.
PETER LUBBERS: Are there
examples of that out there
that you know of?
FRANK SALIM: I would
imagine there are
examples of that out there.
PETER LUBBERS: Efram from the
Canary Islands in Spain, what
is the best way to send binary
data through a WebSocket
connection?
That should be pretty
straightforward, right?
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
You have your JavaScript object
representing the binary
data and you call
websocket.send.
You do have a choice of types.
But really it's the same on the
network, so whatever type
makes the most sense in
your application on
the JavaScript side.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
But I think a lot of the
examples that are out there
are still very much
text-based.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Actually, we do
have an example in the book
that exercises this.
When you drop the image in the
browser and it's sent and it's
sent back again.
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
We have examples in the
book of using--
I think that was using a blob,
maybe the file reader API, to
get the contents of the image.
And once you have the binary
data available, just call on
websocket.send on a built-in,
browser-supported WebSocket.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
I think mainly because in the
early days of WebSocket it was
a text-based protocol.
So I think--
FRANK SALIM: Right.
And I think some of the
libraries, some of the
polyfills don't support binary
or don't support binary in all
situations.
And if you can only send
text-based data, then you have
to encode it in some way.
But if you're using standard
WebSockets, you don't have to
really compromise there.
You can just send a
binary message.
PETER LUBBERS: Like a data URI
or something you would have to
use instead.
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
Base 64.
PETER MOSKOVITS:
Base 64, yeah.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
So Vlad from London asked, what
are the most important
differences between WebSocket
and Flash sockets?
So we mentioned earlier that
were all these other
alternatives.
I guess you don't have
to install a plug-in.
FRANK SALIM: Flash has support
for opening TCP connections
with the flash net socket API.
And it's not really anything
like a WebSocket.
It doesn't have an HTTP
connection up front.
It doesn't have any kind
of framing of the data.
But it does have a separate
out-of-band request to enforce
the security policy in sort of
a strange, nonstandard way.
PETER MOSKOVITS: Yeah.
So in a nutshell, if you have
socket connections from Flash
or Java, you should seriously
take a look at WebSocket,
because that is the
way you want to
move your apps forward.
I think one more thing on the
Flash socket one is that in
order for it to work if you are
behind firewalls, you have
to open a port on those.
With WebSocket, by default
WebSocket being on port 80 and
port 443, you don't
need to do that.
So that's an extra level of the
web-friendliness of WebSocket.
PETER LUBBERS: Pretty big.
PETER MOSKOVITS: That's
a big one.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
OK.
So Don from San Diego is asking
is WebSocket path to
using Bonjour zeroconf
using HTML5?
PETER MOSKOVITS: I'm not sure.
PETER LUBBERS: Any
thoughts on that?
I'm not too familiar
with that.
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
That's a protocol
for configuring
devices on a local network.
PETER MOSKOVITS: That's what
Apple uses, right?
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
I think that--
yeah.
Personally I don't know if
that would be a path to
letting web applications
participate with local network
devices or if that would even be
desirable generally from a
security standpoint.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
Well, we can come
back to that.
From Bangalore, NTRK, what is
the significance of the URL in
WebSockets?
And are they similar
to HTTP URLs?
FRANK SALIM: Yeah.
So since a WebSocket connection
starts with an HTTP
request and response, that
is the URL to which
the request is made.
And yeah, it's an HTTP URL.
PETER LUBBERS: Cool.
So we've got a couple of other
questions and then
we'll wrap it up.
Maybe remind me to have the
coupon for the book.
So are there any hardware
implementations that use
WebSockets, from Fabito, any
hardware-based WebSockets?
Interesting.
PETER MOSKOVITS: I'm
sure there are.
So there are all these little
devices out there Arduinos and
the Pi, Raspberry Pi.
Yeah.
So we have played around
with those.
There's nothing that would
stop these devices from
speaking WebSocket.
I can't think off the
top of my head.
PETER LUBBERS: So we have
two more questions.
Let's just quickly
run through them.
John from San Diego.
Why not use Socket.IO, which
provides the same functions
and also falls back
to Flash and Ajax.
I think, again, it comes back to
the standard, right, having
the WebSocket standard
implemented in all the browsers.
Anything to add there?
PETER MOSKOVITS: Why
not use Socket.IO?
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
Why not use Socket.IO?
PETER MOSKOVITS: I think there's
a lot of people who
use Socket.IO and it
suits their needs.
So it's an excellent choice
in some cases.
It's an open source,
free solution.
So many people find that
as the right tool.
What we found, what we saw was
we had a couple of customers
and prospects who came to us--
we have a commercial product
that scales to larger
enterprises and financial
services at Kaazing.
And what we found was that
there were certain corner
cases that did not quite
work with Socket.IO.
So they came to us and
asked for some help.
But Socket.IO is the right tool
for many people and many
companies out there.
And basically Socket.IO has a
big role that it contributed
to the success of
the technology.
So there's a lot to
be said about it.
FRANK SALIM: And Socket.IO
uses WebSocket.
It's not exactly an either/or.
It's one of the polyfill
libraries for communications
that uses WebSocket as a
connection strategy.
PETER MOSKOVITS: That's the
primary one, yeah, I think.
PETER LUBBERS: All right.
So if there's any other
questions, we'll
take a look at them.
And we'll put in some comments
after the show.
We have to wrap it up.
Two quick questions.
What about any upcoming events
where I can learn more?
I mean, of course, people can
buy the book but, where can we
find you guys?
And how can we get
more information?
VANESSA WANG: We're doing a live
appearance on Thursday in
San Francisco, for the San
Francisco HTML5 User Group.
Ilya Grigorik, who wrote the
forward to our book, is going
to be doing a talk and
performance, which will be a
really great talk.
And the three of us will be
presenting about the book and
doing a book signing.
PETER LUBBERS: Perfect.
VANESSA WANG: So we'll be there
to answer questions and
talk more about it.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
And if people--
PETER MOSKOVITS:
HTML5 Dev Con.
VANESSA WANG: Yes.
PETER LUBBERS: That's right.
All right.
You're going to be there.
VANESSA WANG: Yeah.
We'll also be hosting a booth
at the HTML5 Dev Conf.
I think that's April
1 through 3.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
VANESSA WANG: And that's going
to be in San Francisco also.
And our colleague will be doing
a panel discussion about
WebSocket there.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
And finally the book, you
have a coupon available.
Can you tell us about
the coupon?
40% off?
VANESSA WANG: Sure.
Yeah.
We have a 40% off the
ebook, I think.
PETER LUBBERS: OK.
So we can post it in the
moderator afterwards.
Great.
OK.
So with that, I would like to
thank you, Vanessa, Peter,
Frank for joining us in studio
answering all of everyone's
WebSocket questions.
And congratulations on
finishing the book.
That's a huge accomplishment.
FRANK SALIM: Thank you.
VANESSA WANG: Thanks, Peter.
PETER LUBBERS: Congrats.
And for those of you online,
thanks for hanging out here.
And I hope to see you soon.
Thank you.